this is something that just so many
people get wrong if you follow this
advice it will significantly impact the
quality and professionally of your
PowerPoint presentations hi guys I'm
Henry from from learning welcome to
another episode in my channel this video
is an excerpt of my online course on
creating powerpoints like presentations
in the same way a stock management
consulting firm such as BCG or bain do
as you may know I work myself in one of
those firms for over six years
I created thousands of PowerPoint slides
this is really what my work was all
about for majority of the time and I
gave very valuable knowledge and
insights into how to create these
presentations in most professional jobs
one of the main reasons to use
PowerPoint is to visualize data and to
present data in one chart however how
exactly the data is presented in the
chart and what the chart consists of is
very unclear and you see very elemental
mistakes being done here when you create
presentations in consulting or actually
any business at all there should be one
rule and this is that you should be able
to take out one page of representation
Dec and that the page itself should be
self explanatory to everybody who just
picks it up and reads it and the reason
is that very often these kind of
presentations are not used for Steve
Jobs style keynote speeches or dresses
it's not really meant to be presented
even though of course sometimes this
happens this way but very frequently
these kind of documents are really used
as documents then are shared in the
organization sometimes saved for many
months and years to come and then it is
important that maybe in a year from now
when a new colleague enters the
organization picks our presentation
reads something is able to understand
what was meant at that time especially
because the employee who maybe created
the deck or created a specific page
maybe it's not in the company company
anymore at all right
so this is why it's important that a
page speaks for itself is self explained
taury and nobody needs to be there to
really explain it to somebody but you
can just understand it by looking at it
and this is exactly what this video will
focus on we will talk about how to
visualize data in a diagram and then
specifically how the diagram should be
composed in order for the diagram to be
self explanatory this video is an
excerpt from our course on CEO level
presentations on how to create
presentations like top management
consulting firms like BCG or Bain do if
you're interested to have a look at the
full course and read the reviews of what
other people think about the course have
a look at the video description you will
find a link to the course actually with
a discount coupon included in it let's
jump into it another really crucial
concept when visualizing your data is
the concept of making your charts speak
for themselves and what that means is
the following you know you really have
to think back about how these
presentations how these top management
presentations will be going to use and
the fact is that these presentations
often get sent around among top
management or among other apartments and
then people have your document in their
hand and they want to understand what
they see by themselves without you
needing to stand next to them and to
take their hand and explain every little
thing and sing to them so what's really
important is that you are able to create
your charts and I think this is
especially relevant to charts because
charts can often be confusing to many
people so it's really important that you
are able to create your charts in a way
that they are self-contained speak for
themselves and contain all the
information necessary that are required
for a good compression of them so let's
just look into some things which are
really crucial for that to be possible
so what are the things that should be
included in every chart the first thing
is something like clear description of a
chart so basically what do I see right
and here's just one example so here is a
chart comparing different regions on a
certain kind of metrics so the the title
could be Europe a generic market
dynamics per region and of course try to
do it as tangible and as concrete as
possible
and what's always important is the unit
of measurement so what is actually
showing and you would be surprised how
many you know charts exist out there
presentation that do not even tell you
what the unit of measurement is and I
mean this chance be complicated because
it has three dimensions you have this
one axis you have this one axis and then
the bubble itself the diameter of the
bubble is the dimension for itself and T
of course it's crucial that you give the
unit of measurement of every single
dimension that you use so here it says
percentage of revenue here is the
percentage of revenue away and here kind
of the the unit of measurement is euro
million and well I just want to
highlight this whenever you use
percentage it's always important to
always say you know the percentage of
what is given here and as you can easily
see if you just talk about operating
margin so it's more or less clear that
this is some kind of percentage but
margins are defined in very different
ways right and it's not always given or
not always clear that the margin is
calculated as a percentage of revenue so
really make it clear here that you are
referring to revenue and the same is of
course true for the cater for the
compounded annual growth rate so of
course that is a percentage but the
growth rate of what are we looking at of
the profits of the revenues or what are
we talking about right so always really
make here just make it a good habit of
yours that whenever you write percentage
that you write percentage of something
and make clear what there's something is
another thing that's really important
but very often forgotten is the time so
when kind of from when is this data
coming from what data do I see and here
it's given the year 2014 here is given
the timeframe of the growth rate we're
looking at so here are only two years
and this is really important because
it's not really intuitive what that
would be right because often these
presentations might be go around might
be sent around one or two years later
after you created them and that nobody
knows anymore from day
but even if you created two right now
and you are basing the data on some kind
of research report for instance that you
found somewhere in this case it's some
kind of annual reports it's not a
research research report but you know
the data is coming from somewhere from
some kind of source and the source is
probably not basically created today
right but in the past so make sure that
you indicate clearly from when the data
is so that the audience or your readers
really can know that another important
thing is the legend or chart key so
whenever you use some kind of color
coding or other things that are
necessary to understand use a legend and
here we are using a legend for these
circles to explain that the diameter of
the circles matter that they mean
something diameter based on market size
and then what you see here is that these
two circuits are covered colored so
these are bluegrass the others are gray
so here is not included legend for that
you could truly do that and the reason
why here is not included legend is that
kind of it refers to in the title that
the recommendation on this page is to
focus on these two regions so it's kind
of logical within the structure of the
page why these two kind of countries are
highlighted but of course you could
highlight the tiras way and then what's
always helpful with these kinds of
things is to include the source so where
is the data actually coming from and
often it's some kind of report but even
if you got the data from within the
company for instance you went to the
management accounting department and
those guys gave you some data sets they
mention the department from where the
data is from this also really helps to
make it transparent and often you will
have the discussion in the company that
you know people are looking into
different kind of data sources and one
department you know the data looks like
this the other department the similar
data looks a bit different so always
make sure it's coming from so that it's
relevant and then just the general point
you know any other relevant
qualification of the chart anything else
that is necessary and is required to
really understand what you're seeing put
it on the chart because
people otherwise might not be able to
understand that anymore later and just
one thing that comes to mind what is
often done wrongly in customer service
right so so imagine you conducted a
customer service or you are citing some
kind of resides on some kind of customer
surveys that somebody it's conducted and
what's really crucial with this kind of
data is to include where the customer
survey took place right so was it
European survey or was it a German
survey as you probably paid no no but
from X and I'm actually coming from
Germany or was it an American survey or
was it a global survey because the
implication of the data is very
different if it's a global survey versus
a survey that was conducted in a very
specific country and I mean even in
consulting companies like like mine you
you would find it amazing how often you
you see kind of customer survey data
being sent around with no clear
indication even though this is of course
bad bad practice people forget to write
it and then it's useless right because
you do not really know where the data is
coming from where it was kind of
collected and then this really really
limits the things that you can do with
it with it just one small note that
actually just catched myself so here for
the operating margin we do not have a
year information right so it would be
good practice to include a year as well
so from which year did you took the
operating margin from okay I hope that's
that's kind of clear and I hope that
wasn't too detailed for you but I think
it's really really important to get that
across that you just need to make sure
that you put all the information on your
chart that is required to understand it
and to let it speak for itself don't let
other people guess what your chart means
to really make it clear for them because
otherwise people will be confused and
your nel is this won't be so helpful
thanks again everybody for watching this
video actually it was valuable for you
please press the like button and if you
would like to keep up to date with all
the content that I have
and the next days and weeks please
subscribe to the channel and you will be
informed
I have many pieces of video planned for
the future both on how to create
PowerPoint slide presentations meeting
the standards of strategy consulting
firms but also on other topics on
business and management and to make you
successful in the first years of your
career this is from learning thank you
for watching